hey guys welcome to be our model
lifestyle I'm Nikita I'm Danielle and
today we go me to show you poses with
the eye on facial expressions because
we're doing a furnishing for Daniel and
it says for some businesses yeah last
time we did a video where we focused on
male model poses for beginners but this
time we're going to focus on facial
expression so I hope you guys can learn
something if you have not subscribed yet
please do say won't miss the next video
that means right here we go
[Music]
first of all we're just gonna take some
serious photos of serious expressions
now you have to remember the three
different angles
which I've explained in the beginner
video I'll add it here so you can check
it out if you take photos of the suit
the most important thing is confidence
so that's what we're gonna show today so
you have to look strong with your eyes
right you can play driver as you can go
out break it down I'm gonna go up five
Russ a little bit you can look straight
into the camera I'm very strong
remember the angle is putting five last
straight to the camera and let 45 now
these are all shots that I'm looking at
the camera but don't always look at the
camera look away from the camera all
right let's do if you where I just
looked away from the camera what adds a
little bit of something interesting is
if your face looks the one way that your
eyes looks the other way just a little
bit to the side of the photographer let
me show you how that looks like we're
gonna do the other side for you as well
all right now we're gonna do a little
bit of friendly smiling photos right the
ones that they love and commercials now
the most important thing that you need
to remember is that you need to smile
with your eyes your face will follow
alright so we're gonna start off just by
being friendly okay look at my eyes in
this show
now we're gonna do a little bit of a
grin you know a cheeky grin alright so
now we're gonna smile a little bit more
[Music]
all right now we're gonna show a little
bit of teeth all right now we're gonna
go for big smiles
you have to make it a real don't fake it
just be real just be you keep your smile
how you would smile okay you can play a
little bit around bring your hands up so
that your face is not alone alright guys
so now you have the basics of serious
face the basics of smiles and next is
the basics of bronze now some guys have
a lot of different kinds of bronze right
so just bring whatever you have for me
and I don't have a lot of grounds you
know I can try but there's nothing here
you know so I could try a lot of
different but style but it's not working
so I'll give you what I have all right
so first up remember to bring your
eyebrows a little bit up bring your
mouth a little bit open as well as it
looks more thing
with the enemies that you have the 45
left to the cameron fortified right but
it looks sometimes really cool is if
you're looking down as well or up so I'm
gonna add that with the front so I've
explained the basics of just looking
serious the basics of smiles and the
basics of proms right so next up is pool
I know it sounds strange but some of the
target is special in the east they
cannot ask it to hey look cool give a
cool look you know so as you can do if
you have a lower cool which looks almost
little bit of angry and the second one
is you just look cool work kind of doing
kind of nautical look alright so let's
do those two okay remember your eyes
right your face will follow can add it
frowns in the cooler as well
[Music]
now there's enough another look that I
personally do not like at all but that's
the kind of look where they don't want
you to give any expression to you look
kind of dead right well especially if
the young models that is what is in
right now I kind of really don't like it
but okay that's just mine okay anyway
doesn't move on so the next I'll a next
basic style is going to be the sour
yeast show basically kind of nothing all
right for some people it looks cool
so that's what they're going for so it's
gonna be a cool / no expression feel
okay let's do that it looks really
interesting if you tilt your head a
little bit Oh make it look kind of cool
weird interesting so let's fill the Hat
so you can see how that looks like
I pull this the whatever look you know
it's just like whatever the word mistake
new models made is that they think cool
is narrowing your eyes is this one
see that kind of expression if you do
that the whole time it does look it's
some clients might dig it they might
like it but you cannot use the same
expression all the time all right so now
this is freestyle and just play around a
little group of expressions with the
angles let's go for it
should I go slower all right sorry we're
focusing on it all right I'll go slow
[Music]
okay that's it that's enough kid come
here guys thank you so much that is the
end of the video thank you for watching
Thank You Nikita for the new photos that
have won a portfolio I'll add a link to
her portfolio so you can check out her
works is an awesome photographer and if
you have not subscribed to my channel
yet please do so you won't miss the next
video
that's it thanks guys yeah thumbs up see
in the next video you haven't subscribed
yet please do so you see the next
hey guys welcome to hey guys welcome to
be out in model lifestyle